pasamos a nuestro invitado del día
hablamos del aniversario de way de que
se cumplen 50 años desde que fue
aprobado este histórico fallo Pero
además se cumplen el día de mañana ya
siete meses desde que fue anulado por la
Corte Suprema de Justicia devolviendo el
poder a los estados para legislar a su
manera sobre el tema vamos a hacer el
análisis sobre esta noticia porque desde
que se levantó la protección al aborto
como un derecho constitucional en estos
siete meses en tres estados avanzan el
litigios en cuatro hay medidas mucho más
restrictivas y además en otros cinco
siguen también las batallas legales
vamos a hablar con Alejandra Cárdenas
quien es la directora senior de las
estrategias legales del centro de
derechos reproductivos Alejandra gracias
a usted por estar con nosotros
Gracias a ustedes por invitarme lo que
hubiera sido el aniversario 50 de Robbie
with se convirtió en una jornada de
manifestaciones a favor del aborto días
antes también salieron a manifestarse
los grupos provida hacia el Capitolio al
tiempo estamos por cumplir los siete
meses de la anulación del fallo qué
tanto se ha retrocedido
la retrocedido enormemente todos los
días tenemos noticias de más y más
mujeres que han tenido que recurrir a
medidas desesperadas porque no han
podido acceder a este servicio de salud
ni siquiera en casos en que su vida o su
salud mental su bienestar gravemente
depende de la posibilidad de acceder a
este servicio y como lo hemos visto la
mortalidad materna ya se ha disparado en
los Estados en que existen
prohibiciones totales Y en donde se
están tomando las medidas más
restrictivas y es lo que sabíamos que
iba a pasar porque así como lo
advertimos una y otra vez la mayoría de
las mujeres que buscan este servicio de
salud en el país son madres que viven
bajo la línea de pobreza o en la línea
de pobreza Entonces estamos viendo que
todo lo que advertimos está haciendo
realidad y es una situación realmente
muy triste y muy des para miles y miles
de mujeres en el territorio de los
Estados Unidos su especialidad son los
derechos reproductivos pero de este tema
también hay que hablar en el asunto
político digamos y con la agenda
republicana Qué pasará en su opinión con
la prohibición del aborto en estos dos
años que le queda de mandato a Joe biden
porque sorpresivamente este fue uno de
los temas que pesó bastante en las
elecciones de medio término en favor de
los demócratas es decir es una discusión
que definitivamente está en el centro
del debate y que además no olvidemos
pues va a tener por supuesto peso en las
siguientes elecciones presidenciales
la mayoría de la población de los
Estados Unidos y esto se ha confirmado
encuesta tras encuesta está a favor de
un acceso bastante amplio la mayoría de
la población no quería que se
retrocediera y se tumbara esta decisión
la gente castigó en estas elecciones a
las facciones más extremistas
diciéndoles no vamos a votar ustedes
porque nos parece absolutamente extremo
tomar estas posiciones persecutorias
contra las mujeres sin embargo
pues existe esta facción del partido
republicano que está muy muy en contra
muy bien y tiene una base muy ferviente
para quien este tema es el único tema
realmente importante entonces en
términos de balance de fuerzas políticas
no hay mucho que el congreso con la
composición actual que tiene puede hacer
a pesar de que esta fracción fue
castigada de todos los demócratas no
tienen control de la cámara de la cámara
baja
y pues lo único que puede hacer esta
administración que es muy importante
igual es seguir impulsando medidas
administrativas como la medida por
ejemplo que tomó el fda que es la
agencia que regula medicamentos
recientemente para permitir que las
personas puedan acceder a medicamentos
para un aborto por correo sin necesidad
de estar en persona Aunque igual pues
obviamente necesitan una prescripción
médica y pues esto Solo pueden obtenerlo
en los resultados donde es posible donde
es posible acceder a través de
telemedicina pero en este momento hay
tanto caos jurídico que todavía no está
caro Cuáles son las líneas de lo que va
a ser legal y no entre los distintos
estados es una situación caótica claro
es que justamente sobre ese tema las
pequeñas farmacias se podrán ahora
vender las pastillas abortivas Si
cumplen con ciertos requisitos en
Estados Unidos y aquí yo le quiero
preguntar en medio de todo este caos
judicial que usted menciona cree que
esta medida potencialmente podría
suavizar el golpe de las prohibiciones
que hay en varios estados
va a ayudar pero no va realmente a tener
un efecto tan grande desafortunadamente
porque para la mayoría de las personas
como dije tener acceso a ese médico o a
esa médica que va a ser la prescripción
y saber como tener la confianza de que
para ese médico o esa médica de que esa
prescripción no va a generar que después
termine envuelta en un proceso judicial
Porque si yo envío la prescripción a una
persona que está en estado donde hay una
prohibición Total no está muy claro ahí
Cuáles son los límites de Lo legal o no
Entonces para muchas personas Esto va a
beneficiar pero digamos que en general
en el territorio no va a tener un
impacto tan grande desafortunadamente
hasta que no quede claro todo este tipo
de preguntas jurídicas no de que le
permitan a la gente estar segura de que
no va a ser judicializada quisiera
pedirle a Alejandra que nos ayude con un
poco de contexto sobre cómo está el mapa
de Estados Unidos en este momento en
términos de al principio de esta
entrevista decíamos que hay una
prohibición total en tres estados que ni
siquiera hacen por ejemplo excepciones
ante casos de violación o de incesto
tenemos litigios al menos en cuatro
estados donde Todavía no se ha definido
qué es lo que va a pasar está ese tire y
afloje entre republicanos y demócratas y
hay cinco estados en los que si bien no
se eliminó por completo el acceso al
aborto sí se aprobaron medidas muchísimo
más restrictivas y la agenda republicana
Busca que se siga en camino hacia la
restricción
Sí o sea realmente en este momento pues
aunque en los Estados más poblados hay
digamos una legislación en general más
amable como en California o Nueva York
para dar un ejemplo la mayoría del país
en este momento está viviendo en estados
donde hay distintos niveles de
restricciones
que que impiden realmente pensar en en
este ejercicio y muchas están viviendo
en estados donde
está de facto completamente prohibido
nosotros vamos a seguir
haciendo litigio Estatal recientemente
Tuvimos una victoria en Carolina del Sur
y la corte la digamos la corte más alta
es estado estuvo de acuerdo con que La
regulación que se había pasado en ese
estado violaba la Constitución y este es
el camino que vamos a seguir tomando
para que pues se protejan lo más posible
este derecho en los distintos estados de
del territorio pero es una es una
situación bastante fluctuante todos los
días estamos contra demandando y todos
los días se pasan nuevas regulaciones de
restricción Entonces es un tiro y afloje
y el mapa de que nosotras de hecho
producimos interactivo en línea del
centro
muestra todo el tiempo como estaba
fluctuando este mapa realmente es una
situación que está en constante
movimiento en términos de lo que es
legal y que no